Speaker 1: There's a really good article in
Slate by Jeremy Stahl called The Total Humiliation
of Dr. Oz and Trump in Pennsylvania.
And there's a couple of different perspectives
about what took place in Pennsylvania.
But a great starting point is this article
by Jeremy Stahl.
And Jeremy Stahl points out, most importantly,
Fetterman beat New Jersey based, crudity,
loving TV celebrity Dr. Mehmet Oz.
And Stahl correctly points out it wasn't a
guarantee.
Fetterman ran several points behind the winning
Democratic gubernatorial candidate, Josh SHAPIRO.
It's easy to imagine that a strong Republican
candidate could have beaten Fetterman in a
race that may well determine control in the
Senate.
Indeed, Republicans had a real opportunity
to select that strong challenger, specifically
the relatively moderate hedge fund manager
and former Treasury Department official David
McCormick, who finished second in the Republican
primary by just 951 votes.
Stahl makes the case, and I believe he's right,
that were it not for Trump's endorsement of
Oz, McCormick would have won the primary.
And it is completely plausible that if McCormick
wins the primary, he defeats Fetterman it
quite literally.
If the Senate ends up 5050 in favor of Democrats
because of Kamala Harris as the tie breaking
vote, you could accurately blame Trump for
losing Republicans in the Senate by jumping
in and endorsing Oz rather than McCormick
or staying out of it altogether.
A couple of different things here.
One of the aspects to this race that got very
ugly was essentially the stroke shaming that
took place by many Republicans after John
Fetterman suffered a stroke months ago and
struggling with auditory processing, not cognitively,
but struggling with auditory auditory processing.
The US campaign put out some ads ridiculing
Fetterman health, although as personally said,
it wasn't me doing that, but it was still
attached to the campaign at the debate.
Even some of my viewers, never mind.
The Republicans were kind of making fun of
Fetterman for the way that he was speaking.
And one of the crazy things is, you know,
they were out there calling him and I apologize
for these terms.
They were saying he he's he's a retard.
People were saying he based on how he's speaking,
he's a retard.
His brain damaged, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
He won.
Okay.
At some point when it came to Trump, lost
to Biden, who was in his basement.
That's not believable.
The flip side of it is how humiliating is
it that Trump lost to a guy who didn't leave
his basement?
Right.
Like, if if anyone concedes that that's what
Biden did, it makes it all the more embarrassing
that Trump lost to that guy.
Now, of course, they say he didn't really
lose it was fraud.
Put that aside for a moment.
For all their criticisms of Fetterman, which
include just making fun of the guy for a medical
problem that he had, doesn't it make it all
the more embarrassing to Oz that he couldn't
beat the guy that they describe as a mentally
retarded person?
It should really make them think, Wow, these
candidates are terrible.
Now they may ultimately start claiming fraud,
and some of them are anecdotally or whatever
the case may be.
But Crudités did not take Oz to victory.
And to me, the really scary thing is that
Oz didn't lose by more.
When you look at what happened in Florida,
DeSantis won by 19.
That is brutal.
The polling had the Santos up like 11, which
would be bad enough, and ultimately DeSantis
lost by like 19.
And that is signaling the strength of the
DeSantis wing of the party.
On the other hand, Oz lost.
He didn't even lose by that much, and he should
be glad about that.
But Pennsylvania rapidly becoming the biggest
humiliation for Trump and Republicans.
And we're going to talk about the endorsement
record a little bit later.
Just remember, endorsing incumbents and Republican
nominees in red districts is not a difficult
way to run up your score for endorsements
when you have actual tough races where the
primary winner might actually affect who wins.
In the case of McCormick versus IT versus
Oz, it almost certainly did.
Trump's record is a disaster, and this is
why Rupert Murdoch and some others are pulling
the ripcord and trying to get the hell out
of here.
Make sure that you are subscribed to the David
Pakman show on YouTube or that you've liked
our Facebook page or that you're following
us on Twitch.
That's where all of the streams will take
place.
The upcoming stream in support of Raphael
Warnock will be on those three platforms.
The Trump announcement next Tuesday will be
on those platforms.
Election results on December six will be streaming
Make sure you're following, subscribed, whatever
it is, all completely free.